قبل عقد انشغل كثيرنا بالتنبؤ في المستقبل
حينها قال مستثمر كبير ان المتمردين
الرقمين سيطرون على الصناعات باكملها في
اقل من عقد تحققت النبوءات شركه ناشئه
اسمها كاربانه كبرت واكتسحت سوق امريكا
لبيع السيارات المستعمله بالتجزئه بخطه
محدده وهي التركيز على التكنولوجيا خدمه
العملاء الاستثنائيه من هنا جاءت الفكره
استبدال البيع الافقي بالبيع العمودي
المعنى ان يطلب الزبون سيارته الكترونيه
او اون لاين ويستلمها تماما كما يلتقط
زجاجه مياه من اله البيع
اغرض الفكره ملايين المستثمرين والعملاء
تشجعت الشركه وبنت ثلاثه وثلاثين برجا
موزع في انحاء الولايات المتحده وباعت 110
الاف سياره في 2021 زياده بلغت اربع
74% عن العام 2020 هذه القفزات وضعت
الشركه الصغيره في قائمه فورتشن 5 بعد ان
وصلت قيمتها الى 80 مليار دولار لكن
الجائحه زعزعات خطا امدادات الشركه بسبب
زياده الطلب العلميه على السيارات
المستعمله رجاء قرار الاستحواذ على
الشركات مقابل مليارين ومئتين مليون دولار
وبدوني حسابات دقيقه ولكن برغمه كبيره في
التوسع على حساب الربحيه سرعان ما تركنت
ديون الشركه وخسرت الخساره الكبيره اذ
هبطت قيمتها الثقه السوقيه من 80 مليار
الى
خيار ونصف الملياردو دولار فقط خلال سنه
واحده ما حصل في كارفانا ما هو الا مثال
لشركه واحده من بين المئات التي بالغت
بالرهان على صعود قطاع التكنولوجيا بعد
الجائحه وانهارت امام اول مطب اقتصادي
راحه ضحيته لكن موظفين
ياتي متزامنا مع توظيفات جديده لكن بعقود
مختلفه من تويتر الى متى ومايكروسوفت
وامازون وغيرها العديد من الشركات سرحت
وتسرح الالاف من موظفيها والسبب الرئيسي
وراء ذلك عمليات التوظيف الكبيره التي تمت
وقت رائحته كورونا ولكن هناك الشركه لا
تزال صامده حتى اللحظه ابل تحتفظ بصلبتها
التي ربما تخسر شيئا منها قريبا سبب حسب
بعض التقارير انها عمدت الى تجميد عمليات
التوظيف ايضا عن التسريحات في هذه المرحله
ووفقا لموقع كرنش بيس المختص بالشركات
الناشئه والتكنولوجيه فانه تم تسريحه اكثر
من 50 الف موظف تقني امريكي في العام
الحالي فقط وهذا العدد يمثل اقل من واحد
في المئه من حوالي 6 ملايين الشخص يعملون
في شركات التكنولوجيا الامريكيه فانها
الصدمه للقطاع الذي يفترض ان يتنامى
ويوظفه اكثر بدلا من الفصل